these three places will pay you a lot of
money to move there and the last one is
my favorite the first place is called
albolin Switzerland and they're looking
to pay a family for up to sixty thousand
dollars to move them
alkaline is facing a human extinction
problem they only have around 250 people
that live there so they want you to move
there for 60k
[Music]
place number two Precision Italy
beautiful town in Italy that is looking
to pay you thirty thousand dollars to
move there because they're facing a huge
aging population problem last year alone
they only had 60 births compared to 150
deaths
but the last place is the Greek island
of anti-cantara only has around 50
inhabitants and if you move there
they'll give you a house a piece of land
and pay you 600 a month for the first
three years to live there